I work with youth hockey
in the Seattle area.
And our league has a number of
ice rinks where the kids play.
So with that in mind,
I decided to build a simple app
that highlights all of the rinks
on a map and here it is.
As I move around the map, you can
see pins for the different rinks.
As I touch each pin, it highlights with
the name of that particular arena.
This is Kent Valley.
This is the ShoWare Center.
Or if I zoom up here,
this is my home rink at Renton.
I could, of course, put more information
in here, such as an address, or
even the dates that I need
to be there for a game.
But for
now I'm just going to show the pins.
Let's take a look at how to
build an app like this one.